[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Dienstag die vom Sport hat
Norbert Lehmann schönen guten Abend
schauen wir auf die Themen von heute
Berichterstattung direkt von der Front
die Ukraine hält das aktuell für zu
gefährlich wir sprechen gleich mit
unserem Reporter vor Ort
Deutschlands Autobauer unter Druck auf
der Automesse in Shanghai wollen sie mit
neuen E-Modellen China die Stirn bieten
es ist erst vorbei wenn wir unter der
Dusche stehen Thomas Tuchel gibt sich
kämpferisch vor dem entscheidenden Spiel
der Bayern gegen Manchester City
[Musik]
wann wagt die Ukraine ihre angekündigte
Offensive wann versucht sie die russisch
besetzten Gebiete zurück zu erobern das
ist die große Frage im Moment nach 419
Tagen Krieg Journalisten will die
ukrainische Militärführung nicht mehr
direkt an die Front lassen die russische
Seite hatte das ohnehin noch nie erlaubt
insgesamt gilt die militärische Lage als
festgefahren entlang der Frontlinie gibt
es kaum Bewegung bei der angekündigten
Offensive könnten gleich mehrere Orte
von strategischer Bedeutung sein einer
davon ist ochakif in der Südukraine dort
war unsere Reporter daran Hassan
vor dem Krieg ein beliebter Ferienort
seit Kriegsbeginn geht es um die
militärische Bedeutung der Kleinstadt am
Schwarzen Meer vom Cliff oben sieht man
die Landzunge gegenüber sie gehört zur
Krim dort nur vier Kilometer entfernt
sind russische Stellungen
es ist unser Land unsere Ukraine die
geographischen Gegebenheiten sind kein
Problem für uns wir wissen wie wir sie
nutzen können damit der Feind sich
unwohl fühlt in seinen Stellungen und
weit weg will wir haben das bei der
Eroberung des Westufers im Herz und
demonstriert und jetzt bereiten wir uns
vor auch die andere Seite einzunehmen
auf der anderen der russisch besetzten
Seite besucht Präsident Putin seine
Truppen informiert sich über deren
Verteidigungsfähigkeit es sind Bilder
des russischen Staatsfernsehens
die angekündigte Großoffensive werde
kommen mehr gibt die ukrainische
Militärsprecherin homemjuk nicht Preis
den Feind Russland über das Wann und Wo
zu verwirren ist Teil der Strategie
im Ort leben nur noch wenige Menschen
und das in ständiger Reichweite der
russischen Artillerie die Nervosität
steigt
du weißt das nicht jeden Moment kann ein
Geschoss einschlagen meine Verwandten
sind krank mein Sohn ist an der Front
wir versuchen hier zu überleben
die militärische Bedeutung von ozak kiff
war schon den generellen unter der
russischen Zarin Katharina der Großen
bekannt
bezeichnenderweise richtete sich der
Blick auch damals in Richtung
jetzt ist daran
nach dem neuen Bestimmungen der
ukrainischen Militärführung dürfen
Journalisten nicht mehr direkt an die
Front was steckt dahinter
ja es gibt rote Zonen in die aus denen
dürfen wir nicht mehr berichten und
gelbe Zonen in die Reporter und nur mit
Begleitung von der Armee von Presse
Offizieren reingehen dürfen das
geschieht zum einen so wurde mir heute
gesagt aus
Schutz für die Journalisten sind große
Gebiete im die Russisch besetzt waren
noch immer nicht geräumt und voller
Minen die Artillerie Einschläge sind
auch oft sehr sehr unberechenbar vor
allem im Don Bass ich gehe aber auch
davon aus dass es aus Furcht geschieht
das Truppenbewegungen bekannt werden
könnten das Stellungen bekannt werden
können in denen gerade moderne westliche
Waffen sein könnten wie z.B der Leopard
der für diese groß angekündigte
Großoffensive von großer Bedeutung ist
und ähm so kann man eigentlich sagen
dass dieses klassische Spannungsfeld uns
noch so lange begleiten wird bis die
große Offensive im Endeffekt entschieden
sein wird denn nichts ist im Moment
geheimer als die Vorkehrung zu dieser
Offensive danke schön für diese
Einschätzung
jetzt zum zweiten großen Thema heute
Klimaschutz in Straßburg verabschiedete
das EU-Parlament das nach eigenen
Angaben größte Klimaschutzgesetz aller
Zeiten Kern des Ganzen der
Emissionshandel also das einfache
Prinzip wer schädliche Treibhausgase
ausstößt zahlt dafür das wird massiv
ausgeweitet ulfräule hat mehr
Stahlproduktion von ThyssenKrupp noch
stößt sie tonnenweise CO2 aus der
Hochofen der Zukunft soll aber mit
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben werden
Ausbau der regenerativen Energie ist
absolut erfolgskritisch und deswegen
muss er auch
mit einem völlig anderen Tempo hier in
Deutschland vorangetrieben werden als
das in den letzten Jahren der Fall war
und das hat die EU konkret vor betroffen
sind alle Wirtschaftsbereiche Verkehr
Strom Schwerindustrie die Industrie muss
Verschmutzungsrechte sogenannte
Zertifikate erwerben um CO2 ausstoßen zu
dürfen jedes Jahr gibt es weniger
Zertifikate zu kaufen deshalb kosten sie
mehr so wird der CO2 Ausstoß für die
Industrie teurer und sie wird mehr in
Erneuerbare Energie investieren
das Geld kommt aus dem Verkauf der
Verschmutzungsrechte
wir reden über ca 700 Milliarden Euro
dieses Geld muss zielgerichtet an die
Industrie und an die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zurückgegeben werden damit sie
die erneuerbaren Energien und
Energieeffizienz umsetzen können
Europas klimaplan ist eine Revolution
die viele 100 Milliarden Euro
verschlingen wird die Mehrheit der
EU-Abgeordneten glaubt aber so die
Zukunft des Kontinents zu sichern die
USA und China die haben Milliarden
Programme um genau dort rein zu
investieren in die erneuerbaren Energien
in die klimaneutrale Stahlerzeugung und
da müssen wir auch hinkommen das heißt
wenn wir das nicht tun dann bleiben wir
auch in diesem wirtschaftlichen Rennen
zurück nicht nur bei ThyssenKrupp hoffen
sie dass Europas Energiewende aufgeht
aber sie ist wohl ohne Alternative
wer in der EU in Gas und Atomkraft
investiert der steckt sein Geld in
klimafreundliche Energien so Stufe es
die EU-Kommission ein mehrere
Umweltorganisationen sehen das ganz
anders und haben jetzt Klage eingereicht
ihr Vorwurf Brüssel betreibe
Etikettenschwindel von klimafreundlich
könne keine Rede sein beim Verbrennen
von fossilen Erdgas werde CO2
ausgestoßen und Atomenergie verursache
radioaktiven Müll sagen wir Florian
neuhahn in Brüssel wie bewerten sie das
ist das etikettenschwindel
na zumindest trifft diese Klage hier
einen wunden Punkt in Brüssel da geht es
um ganz grundsätzlich ist nämlich die
Glaubwürdigkeit europäischer
Klimaschutzpolitik dieses umstrittene
Gesetz diese Taxonomie kam im letzten
Jahr nur durch einen Deal zustande
zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich auf
der anderen Seite Frankreich bekam die
Einstufung von Atomkraft als grüne
Energieform Deutschland hingegen die
einstufen von zumindest bestimmten
Investitionen in Gaskraftwerke als
nachhaltig als grün und jetzt stellt
sich schon die Frage was dieses grüne
Label noch wert ist zumal wenn damit
auch Investitionen eben in fossile
Energieträger finanziert werden die ja
auch die ehrgeizigen Klimaziele der EU
unterlaufen über die wir gerade erst
berichtet haben
die Umweltverbände sind in ihrer Kritik
darin auch wahrlich nicht alleine es
gibt viel Kritik auch quer durch die
europäischen Mitgliedstaaten Österreich
etwa hat im letzten Herbst gerade erst
eine Klage eingereicht eine weitere
Klage stammt von einem SPD
Europaabgeordneten mit einem Urteil des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs kann man
frühestens im Herbst 24 rechnen das wird
dann auch ein Urteil über die
grundsätzliche Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit
europäischer Klimaschutzpolitik danke
schön Florian neuer nach Brüssel wie
schwer es ist Klimaschutz umzusetzen das
spürt derzeit auch die Bundesregierung
innerhalb der Ampelkoalition droht neuer
Ärger vor drei Wochen beschloss die
Koalition in einer marathon-sitzung das
Klimaschutzgesetz zu ändern gestern
warnte der Expertenrat für
klimafragender vor mit diesen Änderungen
des Klimaschutzgesetz zu verbessern und
zum Beispiel die Einsparziele für den
Verkehrssektor zu lockern nun droht der
verkehrspolitische Sprecher der Grünen
die unterzeichnete Reform im Bundestag
zu blockieren Theo call in Berlin was
ist da los in der Koalition naja da wird
gerade sehr deutlich wie aufgeraut die
klimasele der Grünen ist auch wenn sie
es nach außen nicht eingestehen wollen
aber einige Ergebnisse dieses
30-stündigen Koalitionsausschusses die
waren für die Grünen ein herberschlag
denn die beschlossene künftige
Aufweichung der unmittelbaren
Verantwortlichkeit einzelner Bereiche
für die Erreichung der Klimaziele die
dürfte dazu führen das ist künftig viel
schwieriger ist das Gesamtziel zu
erreichen der Expertenrat für
Klimafragen hat das ja gestern mit
seiner Warnung vor einer Verwässerung
des klimaschutzgesetzes noch einmal
überdeutlich gemacht und er hat damit in
den Grünen die bisherige Argumentationen
dass das ja alles kein Problem sei
öffentlich entzogen die Änderung hinter
seiner mehrjährigen Gesamtrechnung würde
so vermutete Expertenrat sogar gegen das
klimaschutzurteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes verstoßen und
zusätzlich ger aten die Grünen ab morgen
unter Druck wenn ein Teil der
Umweltbewegung sich in Berlin hier auf
die Straße klebt und die Hauptstadt lahm
liegen will die Reaktion der Grünen war
jedenfalls heute politisches Gas geben
in der Koalition danke nach berlin-
Klimafragen fordern auch die
Automobilindustrie der weltweit
wichtigste Absatzmarkt ist China bislang
haben deutsche Hersteller dort gute
Geschäfte gemacht VW war Nummer eins
doch das ist jetzt vorbei im Moment
werden in China vor allem Autos mit
Elektroantrieb verkauft und da spielen
deutsche Marken kaum eine Rolle Thomas
gonzia berichtet
die Volksrepublik und Volkswagen lange
passte das doch VW ist in China erstmals
seit den 80ern nicht mehr Marktführer im
ersten Quartal ging der Verkauf
gegenüber dem Vorjahreszeitraum um 14%
zurück Hersteller bi.d aus China zog
vorbei plus 68 %. Grund deutsche
Verbrenner verlässlich und beliebt aber
China und Chinas Konzerne wie setzen auf
E-Antrieb die Nachfrage dort steigt
immens und verdoppelte sich zuletzt fast
doch deutsche e-Autos sind in China
Ladenhüter VWs Stromer kommen nur auf
einen Marktanteil von
2,4%. die von BMW Mercedes Audi nicht
mal auf ein Prozent
Gründe schnelle Lieferung digitale
Extras das ist Chinesen wichtig doch da
haperts bei deutschen Modellen die
Gefahr deutsche Hersteller könnten in
China weiter verlieren während Peking
dabei ist den e-automat zu erobern
weltweit
auf der automobil-messe in Shanghai
versuchen gerade alle großen Hersteller
zu pumpen dort zeigt sich auch in
welchen Bereichen die chinesischen
Modelle derzeit die Nase vorne haben von
der Messe berichtet Elisabeth Schmidt
das Auto passen zum Hochzeitskleid
Lifestyle Infotainment und günstige
Preise damit werben chinesische
e-auto-hersteller auf der Automesse in
nur fünf Minuten die Batterie
austauschen statt lange Aufladen jetzt
wollen die chinesischen Autobauer auch
den Sprung nach Europa schaffen wir
können liefern das Thema Lieferzeiten
ist in der Autoindustrie in den letzten
Jahren tatsächlich immer größeres
Problem auch geworden bei uns kann der
Fahrzeug kann der Kunde sein Fahrzeug
relativ schnell mitnehmen das Problem
der deutschen Autobauer ist auf Chinas
Straßen deutlich sichtbar grüne
Nummernschilder stehen für E-Autos blaue
für Verbrenner unter den zehn
meistverkauften Elektroautos in China
kein einziges deutsches Modell
das ist natürlich eine ernstzunehmende
wettbewerbliche Situation vor allem weil
der chinesische Staat auch massiv seine
Unternehmen unterstützt weil auch eine
bessere Situation ist was Rohstoffe was
Energie und andere Themen angeht also
erst einmal müssen wir auch unsere
eigenen Hausaufgaben machen in Europa in
Deutschland in Shanghai Bohlen die
deutschen Hersteller um chinesische
Kunden mit pompösen Shows und
zahlreichen Elektromodellen hier
Volkswagen mit der e-limousine ID 7 die
Nervosität der Autobosse ist groß
Interviews werden lieber influencern
oder dem chinesischen Fernsehen gegeben
400 geladene mediengäste aber kein
Interview für ZDF und ARD wir dürfen
zwar bei der Aldi seven Weltpremiere
zuschauen aber fragen dürfen wir nicht
stellen wir bekommen Interview Absagen
von allen deutschen Herstellern während
und sich chinesischen die Türen öffnen
fast schon symbolisch für die aktuelle
Lage auf dem e-automaten
Bahn und Flugreisende müssen sich wieder
auf Ausfälle und Verspätungen einstellen
die Gewerkschaft Verdi ruft für
Donnerstag und Freitag Beschäftigte in
der Luftsicherheit und Fluggastkontrolle
zum Streik auf und zwar an den Flughäfen
Düsseldorf Köln-Bonn und Hamburg laut
Medienberichten will auch die Eisenbahn
Gewerkschaft EVG am Freitag streiten
in den Sudan dort haben die
Konfliktparteien eine 24-stündige
Feuerpause vereinbart sie soll ab heute
Abend gelten bereits in den vergangenen
Tagen hatte man sich auf waffenpausen
geeinigt die nach UN-Angaben aber nicht
eingehalten wurden seit Samstag liefern
sich die Armee und die paramilitärische
Miliz RSF heftige Kämpfe um die Macht in
dem Land dabei sind mindestens 270
Menschen getötet worden
in ganz Israel haben am Morgen die
Menschen inne gehalten zum Gedenken an
die sechs Millionen Opfer des Holocausts
in diesem Jahr wird besonders an den
jüdischen Aufstand im Warschauer Ghetto
vor 80 Jahren erinnert
landesweit wollten wie hier in Tel Aviv
2 Minuten lang die Sirenen Autos blieben
stehen
gedenken in der holocaust-
nach Freiburg sie haben die katholische
Kirche als Hölle erlebt und als einen
Schutzraum für Täter das Sagen
Missbrauchs Betroffene und fühlen sich
jetzt vom Bericht über sexualisierte
Gewalt im Erzbistum Freiburg bestätigt
über Jahrzehnte wurden dort Taten
verschleiert und Täter geschützt wie in
so vielen anderen Bistümern auch Eva
schiller hat Details auf diesen Tag
wartet Raphael Hildebrandt seit
Jahrzehnten das endlich ans Licht kommt
was ihn quält seit er ein kleiner Junge
ist über 400 Mal missbraucht ihn ein
Pfarrer und lange will ihm keiner
glauben jetzt hatten schwarz auf weiß
also ich spreche jetzt von mir wo ich
sage okay jetzt ist mal aus dem
Schwebezustand einfach draußen und man
weiß es die Kirche steht wirklich die zu
was da wirklich passiert ist was sie
dahin Freiburg enthüllen treibt in
seiner Kaltblütigkeit auf die Spitze was
seit Jahren scheibchenweise aus der
Institution Kirche sickert der
Missbrauch von 600 Kindern und
Jugendlichen von ganz oben verschleiert
vertuscht der Bericht rechnet gnadenlos
ab mit dem früheren Erzbischof Zollitsch
offensichtlich war jener Erzbischof der
Ansicht sexuelle Verhältnisse
einverständlicher Art mit erwachsenen
Frauen seien
strafverfolgungswürdiger als Missbrauch
von Kindern und Jugendlichen
ich muss Ihnen sagen also das
festgestellt haben waren wir erst mal
sprachlos
will sich nicht zum Bericht äußern hatte
die Veröffentlichung rausgezögert sich
letzten August schon mal vorbeugend per
Video entschuldigt ich habe den Aussagen
und Versprechungen der Täter nur allzu
gerne geglaubt und wollte denen eine
zweite Chance geben sein Nachfolger geht
auf Distanz die kirchenrechtlichen
Maßnahmen sind eingeleitet des Verfahren
was ihn anbetrifft seine Situation wird
in Rom entschieden Raphael hildebrand
hat genug von Worten denen kaum Taten
folgen er fordert zügige Entschädigung
und will denen Mut machen die aus Scham
noch schweigen
tja jetzt Sport Fußball Champions League
Norbert morgen wird es ernst für die
Bayern ja nach der 0:3 Hinspiel Klatsche
im Viertelfinale bei Manchester City
muss schon ein mittelschweres Wunder
geschehen zumal München noch nie im
Europapokal im Rückspiel einen drei Tore
Rückstand aufholen konnte aber wunder
gibt es ja immer wieder glaubt auch
Bayern Trainer Thomas
in Manchester sah er viele positive
Dinge im Spiel seiner Mannschaft aber
zahlen beherrschen nun mal den Fußball
und da spricht ein 0:3 eine klare
Sprache in einer absolute
Herausforderung gegen ManCity zu spielen
die absolut die die die beste Form haben
gerade seit Wochen
und das selber in der Verfassung zu
spielen wo uns die ein bisschen abgeht
es gibt wenige Mutmacher Sturmspitze
Choupo-Moting scheint wieder fit die
schwächelnde Bayern Offensive braucht
ihn er hatte im Achtelfinale gegen Paris
ein wichtiges Tor erzielt sadio mané ist
auch da nach Team interner Suspension
sein kabinenstreit mit sané abgehakt es
sind dafür verantwortlich die Zuschauer
mitzunehmen und dann sind wir dafür
verantwortlich alles dafür zu tun eine
absolute Topleistung zu bringen Man City
kommt mit zehn Siegen in Folge angeführt
vom selbstbewussten erlingerland mit
zuletzt 14 Treffern in 6 Spielen da
fällt es schwer an ein bayerisches
Fußballwunder zu glauben
mit einem nur zwei Tore Rückstand geht
Chelsey heute Abend ins Rückspiel gegen
Real Madrid der Titelverteidiger tritt
wieder mit Spielmacher Toni Kroos an der
offenbar seinen Vertrag bei dem
königlichen verlängern will
wer so gestenreich mit dem Trainer
diskutiert wie Toni Kroos ist ein
Mannschaftsführer einer der Spieler die
nicht auf dem Platz eine zentrale Rolle
im Team von Real Madrid inhaben
im Hinspiel gegen Chelsea hätten die
Madrilenen im Estadio bernabeo durchaus
mehr als nur die zwei Tore von Benzema
und nach Groß Vorarbeit von essencio mit
nach London an die Stanford Bridge
nehmen können für Real als deutschen
Spielmacher der auch als Torschütze
Spiele gewinnen kann soll das Match
gegen Chelsea heute Abend nicht mehr als
ein Sprungbrett sein auf seinem Weg zum
fünften Champions League Titel mit
Madrid
ja alle Viertelfinals morgen Abend in
der Zusammenfassung bei uns zu sehen
Sportstudio Champions League 23 Uhr ich
hatte ein bisschen gehofft dass du
diesen Punkt nach machst aber das heute
nicht mehr
für Dino Freunde mit viel Geld und
riesen Anwesen gab es heute in Zürich
was ganz feines Trinity das Skelett
eines Tyrannosaurus Rex umgerechnet rund
5,6 Millionen Euro zahlt ein anonymer
Bieter aus Europa für die etwa 65
Millionen Jahre alten Knochen sie
stammen von drei Exemplaren daher der
Name zusammengesetzt ist Genitiv fast 4
m hoch und 12 m lang
Morgen gibt Sonne aber auch Schauer
Details zum Wetter hat gleich erst den
Termin
heute journal und wir sind morgen wieder
da danke für Ihr Interesse einen schönen
Abend noch auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eigentlich
herrscht Deutschland weit hoher
Luftdruck aber ein kleines Tief aus dem
Osten schmuggelt sich nach Deutschland
es ist ein Höhentief und ihr Barometer
wird das gar nicht anzeigen trotzdem
gibt es Schauer und Gewitter in den
östlichen landeszahlen im Süden Regen
der kann auch länger anhalten nach
Westen zeigt sich längere Zeit die Sonne
die Details im Südosten viele Wolken und
hier macht sich das Tief schon bemerkbar
mit etwas Regen sonst klagt es vor allem
nach Norden hinauf und die Temperaturen
gehen zurück auf 0 Grad in der
norddeutschen Tiefe Ebene hier der
tiefswert und 8 Grad am mildesten ganz
im Westen Deutschlands und zu morgen
dann Aufzug im Tagesverlauf dann von
schauen und einzelnen Gewittern im Süden
dicht bewölkt mit Regen sonst aber im
Nordwesten Sonnenschein und ein strammer
Nordost wenn es dabei an der Ostsee
Sturmböen mit höchsten Temperaturen von
5 Grad im Osten und 16 Grad z.B am
Niederrhein die kommenden Tage ja am
Donnerstag noch mal sehr durchwachsen
mit schauen und Gewittern bei 5 bis 15
Grad danach wird sonniger und auch etwas
wärmer damit ein schöner Abend